okay let's move on to our next subject
shall we because earlier in the show we
heard how hydrogen-powered planes
could make flying more sustainable now
hydrogen doesn't produce any co2
emissions its only waste product is
water so could this be the start of
guilt-free flying i mean vicki
everyone's going to like the sound of
that so what do you make of this project
to try to develop a liquid hydrogen fuel
aircraft
well if it were to work that would be
absolutely brilliant
it's been talked about for some time but
the interesting thing is that the
airline sector that accounts for
something like two percent of global co2
emissions are present but rising has
already managed to improve its
efficiency very significantly but i
think that would make a huge difference
i mean we know that it isn't going to
solve the problem completely in terms of
aviation because there are lots of other
things that come out in the atmosphere
when you fly at high altitudes but it
will certainly make a big big difference
because basically the co2 would no
longer be emitted it would just the
waste would be water but if you're able
to do long distance and have the right
aircraft that is able to support it then
obviously will make a tremendous
difference in terms of how we can
envisage the future in a clean sort of
net zero environment which hydrogen i
think can do and there are expectations
that it might actually by 2050 supply
something like 25 to 35 percent of all
energy needs
delica how optimistic are you
i think there is an extraordinary press
release by the government if you read
the detail in it it says if the
technological
barriers which they say are big are
breached then they may produce a plane
by the 2030s or 2040s what's going to
happen to aviation during the 20s and
30s as we emit a huge huge amount of
fossil fuels and the second issue both
of you have mentioned water as a
byproduct of hydrogen planes
50 of the global warming emissions from
planes currently come from voter vapor
it heats the planet so what we will do
with this plane is we'll reduce the
carbon emissions by 50 percent and
double
double the the eva the water vapor
emission so we end up with the same
amount of global warming this is
nonsense we need to do what the
government needs to do to tackle the
vast amount of people who are rich who
are flying unnecessarily four percent of
the global population fly abroad each
year we need to tackle the frequent
flyers with attacks and reduce that
wasteful common emissions very briefly
respond to that vicky
the water vapor aside just the fact that
short-term people need to fly less and
there's a huge proportion
of people that
don't fly at all what about the others
well um the the truth is of course that
flying has brought lots of lots of
countries together and has encouraged
growth and remember that flying isn't
just for the pleasure of people it
actually carries a lot of freight so
what's been happening recently in
particular given that we had problems
bringing anything by sea is that
airplanes have substituted if you like
moved in to to take off that load and
ensure that supply chain works so we
shouldn't look at flying it's just
something that people who can afford it
can do very you've got 10 seconds you're
shaking ahead
yeah replacing um shipping with air
freight is probably quadrupling the
carbon emissions from that transport if
not more it's
completely unsustainable to be switching
to airplanes for freight